so if you get married what do you want
that marriage to look like oh um if I
get married I would like I would like to
have a guy that I can try I look at it
similar to my relationship with like my
dad which I don't know if that's is that
weird I don't know I was thinking about
this the other day but like some will
have a problem with how you worded it
but it's up to you it's your word okay
because I think of my dad and same with
my brother like I'll give you an example
I trust my dad so much I hate accounting
my dad makes me do the accounting myself
every month and every month I'm like why
can't we hire an accountant I don't
understand why I do this myself and my
dad's like look at it you you have to
know your numbers you have to do
my dad's like that too yeah and I'm like
fine and I do it because I trust my dad
because I'm like my dad wouldn't like
steer me insane with uh my brother Adam
it's really similar too
um and that's kind of a relationship
that I'd like to have similar with my
husband where even if like I disagree
with him I it's like you trust his
judgment so would you want to work
I'm I'm okay with not working if I mean
yeah that's fine yeah see I you know and
it's funny because we talk about like
who bought the story and I feel like I
bought a lot of the story for years you
know I I really did I was like I was
somebody like I came out of college and
I was like I really didn't want to work
that hard I really didn't in fact I got
offered a great job with Lancome when I
first came out in makeup company and
they were like you have to travel and I
was like oh no I'm not traveling for
work I don't want to do that I want a
sunbathe on the back you know and I want
to have my Summers
um but I did buy a lot of the story of
like don't lean on a man like it's
dangerous to lean on a man like you've
gotta like it was like an expectation
that Society had that I was gonna follow
some sort of work path so I think it's
interesting like to see all of these
women that do that and then land I'm
trying to like shake them like is this
something you really want or is this
something that you think you're being
told that you should want but in reality
inside you're like that's not for me
quit one job I'd do it again
I worked an insurance company and I
remember dude I went to they were like
oh it's a really great opportunity for
you one of my first jobs out of school
and they were like but you have to you
know you're gonna be able to do more
work and I was like oh I'm out I told
the boss straight up I was like that's
funny I don't even I mean YouTube is a
job now but other than accounting I look
at that [ __ ] as a job I just love it
like I do so you're having a good time I
just I literally just love like doing
this it's just fun you know it's kind of
like some girls get really into like art
I've just always been curious I love
having conversations with people and I
love finding out like stuff that's true
and so when I started listening to Red
Pill content I was like oh my gosh this
is gonna I would say roller ruin church
for me he did foreign
I couldn't unsee it and I couldn't unsee
it
so you but you say you were a little bit
more blue pilled was there was there a
moment for you where you were like oh
wait a minute I think it was when I was
on the show and I could just
oh after you started the content
um I would say there's there no okay
because it's hard because different
things I changed like opinions on I've
always been more conservative and I will
say conservative like lines up with a
lot of this stuff but when I think of
cheating
okay when I was explaining to girls that
like that top guys in society will cheat
I understand like the men explaining
things to me before because you'd be
like well but my dad and like and I'm
like we're not talking about you Rebecca
there's actually no girl named Rebecca
but and I just started to understand
like the things that men would say like
when they would be like oh girl like
girls are with their emotions and I'm
like well I'm a logical girl we're not
talking about you Pearl and I just
started to understand like where the men
were coming from when partially when I
was doing the show and when I just
listened to enough of like what guys
were saying talking to guys in my life
and I was just like wow this stuff is
true you can't run from it yeah it's
crazy it's like you having a like in a
moment I was gonna use the word Epiphany
but then that pulls from Rolo so I don't
know it's a whole different meaning but
it's crazy that you like you have a
moment where you're if you're willing to
kind of sit back and like think you're
like oh [ __ ] that makes sense that's why
I love I I red pilled my friend for the
the first time like that's one of my
favorite series I've been doing less of
them lately but you can only do so much
I've been traveling but but um I that's
my favorite series I've done on my
channel because you can just see the
wheels turning like on these girls like
for the first time like and they were
even further back than me where you're
talking about like the pay Gap but when
you explain the pay Gap to girls that
have always believed there is a pay Gap
it's like you see the wheels turning and
they're like oh so that's not real well
I saw that in the panel you had with
Aunt with Tate recently I was watching
the women and it started off like
everybody kind of had their armor on but
as the conversation kept going I saw
like they were like oh and it was it
became more of like a like a listen
learn think respond like it was it was
fascinating like throughout the course
of that show to see like everybody
initially like ready to fight but then
like actually having a conversation so I
think that it's great people should go
watch that episode by the way if you
haven't already it's got like a zillion
views already but it's funny the girl in
the middle so the one thing people don't
know about the show is a lot of times
you you girls that disagree I prioritize
to come back I mean they don't always
want to but but and the girl in the
middle denalva it's funny to see her
Evolution on camera I mean I'm sorry
danova you're crazy I'm Gonna Stand by
oh we've covered her here yeah she crazy
but it's funny she gets a little less
crazy like that she starts to agree more
with us the more she comes on the shows
where I'm like denounce was agreeing
with me and so it's like it's funny to
see girls like Evolution on camera
because like a lot of people will say
like grifter you pair like whatever
whatever but the truth is the truth like
what's true is like true you can't run
from what's true that is true and it's
also like I feel like women don't
haven't really taken the time to think a
lot of this stuff through sometimes you
don't have to we don't have to we were
like we just kind of go through life and
then you sit back you have a
conversation or you hear other people
and you actually start thinking about it
and you start looking at your life and
you're like oh wait a minute I did do
that oh you know like things start
piecing together in different ways if
you're willing to kind of have that
self-reflection Deli we got more hey
yeah we actually have a lot okay we're
gonna close with chats today so let's
have them all right we have
George Butler said love both of your
content miss the first part Pearl but
you have this you have a second Channel
tell us more about it um
well I actually have like a lot of
traveling
keep up oh it's I I have a system I it's
it's hard to explain and like but I'll
explain it to you off camera I just have
a whole system where it kind of works
without me doing anything oh that's good
yeah but the yeah that's wife school and
it's where we have uh me I I start with
it before everyone's like you're not a
wife I'm not teaching okay
um we have women
um we may have men do Chef or like style
it like that oh cool other people might
come into everyone's like well where are
the wives they're coming okay wait
teaching modern women like myself how to
be more traditional there you go yeah
had a dress there's a whole bunch of
stuff yeah yeah Casey said love you
Pearl and Jed take and have children
from multiple women because he is a
modern day King but nagami is functional
for the everyday people who live inside
the Matrix but he is outside the Matrix
he is outside the Matrix
um I think monogamy has a good purpose
in all of the site just my opinion but
there are going to be exceptions
um but are you into the Matrix content
too I'm all over that the Matrix stuff
like are you into the political side of
that stuff no I kind of have like okay I
have a general idea where there's I kind
of wanted to do a red pilling myself
series on this stuff like it's
population control is what they think
and a lot of policies are like towards
population control and there's like a
group of Elites or something that are
involved in names I've heard
don't don't do anything to me but the
clintons
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible